foreign
[Music]
smile conceals a secret and it's a
sickly sweet that I can't see the point
of taking deeper and through a surface
that it's just so beautiful
[Music]
I don't wanna spoil yourself
please don't leave this too oh cold
your eyes make me feel dizzy
when you quiz me on my childhood history
I'll share with you if you feel
kindly cut me oh so I can't see
[Music]
straight onto me but instead I enjoy
this view that's hides so shallowly
I don't wanna spoil my soul
please don't leave this to go cold if
the best things are worth waiting for
would you disagree would you only see
them now right here's where we both are
afraid to turn around and see how far
and see and see how far
cause I can't wait forever I'm not that
patient I've got too many things
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone oh my gosh not that long
thank you so much for coming and happy
000 subscriber celebration I was gonna
say anniversary but that's not the right
word for a celebration look at us go
thank you thank you so very much to
everyone who is here has watched my
videos uh and has supported me in one
way shape or form I feel like I've been
on YouTube for like a good long time now
I
to me so I thought I would just hang out
with you on YouTube because I don't do
YouTube live streams very often so hello
nice to see you let's see who we've got
here
I hope you can hear me and things let me
know if not usually I stream on Twitch
so I had to like make sure everything
was also working for YouTube I might
have forgotten some stuff but we shall
see Hello air apparent oh is that air or
hair hair is or was it like air like are
you royalty I don't know welcome hello
Luke Parker's Haskell hello D Crow Hello
Alex 062 hello explosive cookie hello
crumb
hello hello hello hey Jamie Hey Sydney
to hey Gaza hey Bruce
see this is what I wanted to do on
YouTube because I'm I'm seeing a lot of
people that I see often in twitch but
I'm sure I will also see a lot of people
that I don't often see uh just on
YouTube so yes hello uh thank you for
coming what were we doing today is just
chatting getting to know one another
I'll do like a live q a so if you have
any questions for me please feel free to
drop them in the chat
um but I'm also gonna play some songs
and a thought maybe we would watch my
first ever YouTube video together
I don't know if I've done that on stream
before if I have it was a very long time
ago and uh I'm not looking forward to it
I've already got it up ready I haven't
watched it yet don't worry
but um I I don't want to watch it
because it's just gonna be so cringy
um but yes should be a good should be a
good time we shall see happy 50k thank
you so much Miss Carter oh look at yep
your royalty knew it knew it a 50k
YouTube Celebration on YouTube
wow he would have thought it you guys
might not know this but I was actually
here for a subscriber joke
who was oh my gosh I probably recall
some of my oldest subscribers uh
whenever they come back in it's crazy to
think how long I've been doing this now
it's uh a long long time and it's so
cool to see people pop back in every now
and then I love I love hearing from
people who have watched me for a long
time and uh seeing how we've grown look
at us we've grown from little babies
into
bigger babies do you ever really grow up
I don't know maybe in some ways
embrace the cringe okay I will try I'm
having fun with these reactions I don't
know how they work exactly we'll see
we'll see this is my first proper
YouTube streaming many many years hey
hey
Hoy munli I'm so sorry if I'm butchering
anyone's names right now I'll try try
not to what I mean but I'll just try to
say your name but I might be butchering
them but thank you very much for the
happy 50k and thank you for being here I
really appreciate it your unreal
tutorials brought me here yes I hate
Nikki
nice to have you here
um so if anyone is wondering who drew
these beautiful pictures am I starting
soon screens that was Nikki so thank you
so much Nikki for the pictures you're
very talented being
um but yeah I've uh been doing YouTube
for a while and I feel like
um this year like basically the past
year I've found my Niche everyone talks
about finding their niches I like these
sleeves um but I feel like I've found my
Niche which is yeah Unreal Engine
tutorials but also kind of how to use
game engines in a more broader creative
sense
um because I feel like that's something
that not many other people are tapping
into but it's definitely becoming more
of a thing I I've actually maybe it's
just because I make the type of videos
but I've seen quite a few videos
recommended to me that's like making
films in Unreal Engine so it's
definitely becoming more of a thing but
I am
I am very happy to be a part of that
community and it seems like you all
enjoy the content as well so that's
exciting yeah we should be getting a new
YouTube video on Monday but we shall see
um patreon should be getting it this
weekend so exciting because uh Jamie and
I have finished another song and we're
working on another music video obviously
and I'm real engine and this time
instead of making it and then telling
you how I made it I'm doing this super
super scary thing where I just take you
along the journey with me and talk to
you about how it's going like month by
month
um which could be a really stupid idea
for me to do because
there's a lot of ups and downs when it
comes to creating things like this but I
guess that's that's the whole point
right of me sharing with you my process
and where things go wrong as well as
where things go right I think that's
what I like to do on this channel we're
not uh we're not all Geniuses at Birth
maybe some of us are I definitely am not
and that's perfectly okay
next 50k should roll up faster oh golly
gosh we shall see it would be lovely to
have that little plaque just just
something like YouTube's like we
recognize you now like wow that would be
nice
but we'll see I'm very happy with 50k so
thank you so much I really appreciate it
I remember when we told you to do
tutorials back then no but I don't
remember but sorry I'm joking
um
yeah I kind of like dabbled in it for a
while and then I did think I wasn't good
enough for a while along I still think
I'm not good enough to be honest I don't
know if you ever get to a point where
you think you're good enough I think
people just fake it and then
just get
good at faking it I don't know all
comfortable in Faking It
but um I think the more you put yourself
out there the more you um
you just get more comfortable doing it
you know
yeah
you were a Pioneer I wouldn't quite say
that but thank you I'll take it I'll
take it thank you
okay so I am going to start off with a
little song just to kind of get us I
don't know in some kind of happy mood
you know and uh yeah if you have any
questions for me feel free to ask
um we're not going to jump straight in
with me watching my first video because
I don't want to
so I'll let you wait a little bit longer
and uh yeah maybe in like half an hour
or something we'll watch that video
together and we will cringe and go wow
look how far you have come and also you
were a baby and I'll be like yeah I know
I was a baby
technically Game Dev related vids but
still the same thing nobody knows what
they're doing exactly do you Crow
no one knows what they're doing she's
getting choked up literally yeah I'm
trying not to cry
ah thank you so much for being here
okay let's get my thing on I have my
ukulele right here so I'm just gonna
pick it up
get my sleeps out of the way
I am so happy that you're no that's I'm
joking
okay
[Music]
I'm gonna sing Tainted Love it always
goes down well and it's a nice upbeat
song because usually I sing sad songs
foreign
[Music]
yes and that's not nearly all
don't touch me Tainted Love I can't
stand the way you tease
[Music]
because
there you go what is your mug today it's
it's Star Wars It's always Star Wars
It's just pictures of Star Wars
so for our song tedded My Love uh but
it's from like a BioShock Infinite
version so it's like an old school
version of the song
yeah
thank you very much
and uh I don't know if anyone here
was at develop bright and developed yes
no it wasn't yes well it was yesterday
it was Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I
think yag music emote oh wait can you
put emotes into YouTube I don't even
know maybe I need to have subscriptions
turned on or something for that
um but yeah I went to Brighton develop
um
I only went for one day I only went for
the Wednesday
new music when oh it's coming we've well
we've made two singles well one single
is almost wrapped up another single is
wrapped up another one was done for that
that was for another person so probably
won't be hearing that one for a while
um but yes the new music is coming it's
always being made just takes a while to
get that out oh and October my next
music video which I will be sharing a
video with you about that on Monday
my employer didn't send me this year oh
yeah neither did mine I just took the
day off so um yeah I went to develop and
uh to be fair it's easy for me though
because I I live in Brighton and was
really nice like I wasn't really sure
what I was gonna do there I didn't
really know who I was gonna meet I ended
up meeting someone I hadn't met in over
a decade in this very long time turns
out he's a friend that I knew from
school and like him and his fiance now
um both back in the games industry is
like a small world and then I just met
some other people
um
soon trademark yes exactly said but yeah
I had a really
um good time because I was like walking
around it's really intimidating those
places isn't it because there's just so
many people and especially if you live
online like I do like the Twitter and
stuff you see a lot of people that you
recognize and you're like do I know you
or do you just have like a recognizable
face I don't know
um so I was just kind of like walking
around and ah this girl came up to me
and it was so sweet because she was just
like hi um you're Yasmin right I was
like yeah and she's like I just wanted
to say like thank you
um so much for your YouTube and stuff
um I've been watching you for a long
time and I thought I was too stupid to
like get into the games industry because
I wasn't that good at math and stuff but
then I found you and I saw like you know
you don't have to be like mathematical
genius or whatever and um yeah and now
she's working at unity and I was like
yeah get you girl go it made me
really happy and I was like
it's nice it's just nice to know like
when you work from home in your room
like your bedroom you just kind of
forget that like sometimes you're like
what am I doing does this even matter
um but yeah now it was nice
uh I think there's a plug-in better for
better emotes on YouTube damn
you gotta get a plug-in why aren't
YouTube on this I mean they have these
reaction things
um but you'd think they'd have like
emotes and stuff do you uh even
integrate AI or chat GPT speed up or
help you with your work no I I don't
like AI um sorry
um I think I understand if you're a solo
Dev and you've got to do everything
yourself and you're not very good at it
fair enough use AI but um for me like
the beauty of making things is in the
process of it and why would I want to
speed that up using AI because
yeah that would be my piece of work like
that wouldn't be my journey that
wouldn't be my process
um but that's just that's just me
because I I love writing so like I've
had people say to me before about I'm
writing a story and it's taking years
and they're like why don't you use chat
TPT or just make it quicker I'm like why
would I do that to myself I want to
write my own story I want it to be like
a journey for me and my creativity and
you know like Stephen King like doesn't
even know where his stories are gonna go
he just lets the characters take control
and like that's I think the beauty of it
um it's it's not AI because he's not
just being like make this happen make
this person do this and then the AI
writes it he'll be like okay I have a
rough idea of like the scenario but I
don't really know what my characters are
gonna do so then it's like a creative
exercise of like oh okay well this one
thinks this way about it and maybe
they're going to be conflicting because
of this and yeah I don't know to me
the creative process you get so much out
of it like as a person
um it it outweighs the outcome of it and
I think AI helps you get to the outcome
faster but then it has a
it
um
uh what's the one at the detriment of
the
um the journey and what you can get from
the journey if that makes sense yeah
um
but anyway that was uh me answering a
question thank you for the question I
guess maybe we can we can jump into
answering some questions
um I do have some questions in my
Discord but I don't think they're here
right now and they said they wanted to
be in the Stream for it is unusual
illusion here let me know if you are
here when you're here because they ask
some nice questions in the Discord
hey Edward westmoreline Contour I'm
really busy right now but I had to stop
and say congratulations on 50K thank you
so much so proud and happy for you keep
being an awesome Legend also I agree hey
I can die in a hole
so much I really appreciate that let's
do some confetti poof confetti there
improve
thank you so much I really appreciate
that hey Maria Ah that's a name I have
not seen in a long time how you
doing well
oh it's so nice it's so weird being back
on YouTube in live
um what is your history in horror games
asking because you were very passionate
about the fixed camera games yes very
true Hui uh again I'm sorry if I'm
saying that wrong
um you can you can uh tell me if I am
and I'm sorry
um but uh yeah my so my history in
horror games
um I think I have I have a lot of love
for horror games because I wasn't
allowed to play them as a kid my mom was
like very strict on horror games and
horror films like to the point where in
Indiana Jones uh I can't remember which
one but there's an Indiana Jones film
where they um they get to drink they
have to drink out of cups and it's like
a challenge and one dude drinks out of a
golden cup and turns into a skeleton
um and my mum would always be like don't
watch
it so like literally anything who we
okay gotcha thank you
um so anything remotely scary my mom was
I don't and I think that made me more
curious about like fear and horror and
stuff and then I just fell in love with
like Goosebumps
um you all the kitty scary things I've
got some Goose book books uh back here
actually
um and also I lived on a street with um
some kids who lived down the road for me
and they loved horror and they would
tell like horror stories to one another
right there was a story that the older
brother used to tell about a decapitated
head that used to like go up the stairs
and it was like I'm on the first step
I'm on the second step but I think
that's the horror story that's been
retold and retold over the decades
um but it fascinated me and I loved it
and then they showed me
um horror games they actually showed me
horror board games for us I'm freaking
ranting on here aren't I
um they show me horror board games which
I thought was fascinating because it
came with like a videotape and um there
was like a spooky man and he would tell
you how to play the game I don't really
remember because I was very young um but
I just remember being like this is
freaking cool and then they showed me
alone in the darker New Nightmare on the
PS1
and it it blew my little mind because I
was I was terrified I was hiding on the
the duvet and um he couldn't figure out
where to go uh actually I've got alone
in the darker New Nightmare now and oh
my God that game is like
difficult as in the design is awful it
doesn't tell you what to do and a lot of
the time you're just wondering what to
do so of course my friend was really
lost and he went to the toilet
and then I decided to pick up the
controller and be really Brave and I was
wandering around and then I could just
looked at a door and got teleported into
this new room and I walked around pitch
black walked around and then all of a
sudden at the window just
just some lightning and then you just
saw monsters in the pitch black room
surrounding you only when the lightning
struck and then there was this noise
like oh it always was like and just
like Chuck the controller and the
Monsters weren't actually there it was
just a jump scare moment and then when I
went back to pitch black you were
actually okay again but I freaked the
hell out and it's just little moments
like that that I just couldn't ever get
out of my head it's just the um I
totally understand why people don't like
horror but I love it it's like it's like
a roller coaster for me and it just it
allows you to explore parts of yourself
that like in a in a safe environment
that you wouldn't be able to or I mean
you probably could explore it in real
life but you probably wouldn't want to
um but yeah oh God it I just loved
horror just loved her I always have done
and then I always used to write horror
stories in Primary School uh and my my
mom actually got a phone call from
someone in the school like is your
daughter for a cake she always writes
about death and she's like yeah that's
just who she is just who she is don't
worry about it ah like Monsters and
death but that's what gets me going
that's what gets my creative juices
flowing so I guess everyone's different
um but yeah I used to love writing
stories about that
Corey barlog said that stuck with me
what did Corey barlock Say Nikki
on the no one knows what they're doing
theme anyone in Creative should
understand that one is always learning
the day you stop learning you should
retire yes I a hundred percent a hundred
percent agree with that yeah I think
honestly that's like hey Leon hello
thank you for coming I think that's
honestly
um
well like one thing that I would just
give advice to anyone especially going
into the games industry or just anything
creative where you work with a team
thank you so much for subscribing down
and low
um
it's a I'm supposed to have some sort of
like alert but for some reason it's not
working so yeah I told you I probably
haven't set up YouTube right but I
appreciate the subscription thank you I
can see you've done it
um what was I saying
stuff oh yeah you don't need to know
everything and it's not about getting to
know everything uh even if you are an
indie Dev on your own you still don't
need to know everything like you have a
community in YouTube and the internet
and thank you internet you know and it's
it's totally it's totally fine
um I think really it's about being
humble recognizing what you don't know
where your constraints are what you're
not very good at what your strengths are
as well your strengths apparently mine
is not talking well your strengths are
but also where you aren't very good and
that's where other people can get
involved or you just kind of
yeah use those as constraints I think
constraints help with any creative thing
anyway
um so you love horror but also love the
psychology of what makes her a heart yes
absolutely Edward like Silent Hill two
love the psychology in that I think um a
lot of horror games nowadays not all of
them I think they're coming back into a
good place but for a while they became
just like jump scare Central where they
didn't really explore any like common
themes or relatable stuff it was just
like you're in a spooky house and
there's a ghost and it's gonna pop out
now
and those are entertaining um but it's
nothing that uh challenges you or sticks
with you and makes you think afterwards
I think Stephen King has
a quote on horror that's like there's
three different types of horror there's
Terror which is the horror that you
strive to do it's like the best form of
horror it's what leaves the audience
um thinking about the piece afterwards
and still being scared in the night time
thinking about it but then there's also
just like I can't remember the other two
there's I think Gore
um and something else where it's just
it's just a little bit cheaper
especially the gore one because it's
just like oh it's disgusting it's gross
but then in the moment it's a bit
shocking maybe but then afterwards
you're like it's fine
but uh yeah I feel like a lot of horror
games went down that route for a while
I love fixed camera angle horror but a
few of my friends seem to hate it so
I've literally been trying to implement
fixed camera angles first person and
modern 3D at the same time almost there
that sounds interesting Chrome
um I wonder how you're doing that like
with the control scheme if you're still
sticking with first person and modern at
the same time first person in modern 3D
like because the only way
fix well the only way the fixed camera
angles from like Resident Evil at the
old games work was because of tank
controls because you end up just getting
confused about where the hell you're
going when you don't have the Tango
drills I think that's what people
struggle with the most because time
controls don't work as well with analog
sticks
um
but yeah best of luck I'd love to see
what you do I think that's also where um
the medium kind of fell off a little bit
because they tried to bring back uh
fixed camera angles didn't they but it
just they just it wasn't as it wasn't as
good as
uh Resident Evil and Silent Hill all the
old ones I have a whole video on that if
you if you want to see in detail I
toggle the control layout oh okay this
cool disco I like this
oh if you have any update videos on
YouTube or like Twitter or anything let
us know that sounds really interesting
and yeah so you have the best of both
worlds basically that sounds good that
sounds really good
he looks like here
what says there's some people who say
like why don't the new say the new
Resident Evil remakes or something why
don't you give them an option to be
fixed camera like they used to be but
also third person and
in my mind that's just near impossible
because you'd be making like
almost two separate games essentially
because things are laid out like
especially level design it's laid out in
a certain way when you use fixed cameras
um versus over the shoulder or first
person or whatever
um I feel like even the jump scares
would be different
um
yeah I don't know I I personally don't
don't think that would work and I don't
think it would be as simple as as people
think it might be
what is your opinion on how tormented
Souls has tank controls with the
directional pad and free control to the
left
stick to my I haven't played tormented
Souls so I have not a clue I have not a
clue time controls of the direction of
pad and free controls the left stick I
mean that sounds great but it's
tormented Souls uh fixed cameras because
if so then probably time controls works
better but I mean if you give players
more options I think that's a good thing
honestly
um like for accessibility as well it's a
really good thing to give them an option
for how they would like to play Things
um
what was it Brayden was playing like God
of War and apparently there was an
option in God of War where you could
toggle it on and press down the stick
and it would show you where your next
route was so if you didn't want to miss
out on any side quests or you didn't
want to you know how sometimes you you
run one way and then you trigger a
cutscene and you're like I can't go
back into that last area anymore so it
basically stops that happening and I
didn't even think about that I thought
that was such a good idea so I'm going
out of tangent now but yeah any if you
can give a player
um options I think that's I think that's
a really good idea but I haven't played
fermented sauce so I can't really talk
on that specifically
it's fixed camera yes
uh to this day oh Soma I still think
Soma is one of the best horror games
ever made simply because of its promise
an existential concept yes yes wait let
me have a look at so much because I
pretty sure
pretty sure I played that did I play
this I don't know it was a while ago
oh yes
the AI was quite like spooky in this as
well
I remember there was a moment I think I
actually watched Braden play this there
was a moment where
oh God yeah like the humans were being
turned into like
like uh robots and stuff yeah spooky
um there was a moment where one of the
monsters
uh was following you and then Braden
like crawled into a room and I was like
shut the door shut the door and then he
did and we were like ah and then it
opened the door and we're like no
no when you learn the monster can climb
ladders or open doors you're like oh
or jump
he's like oh no I'm screwed
uh yeah but I agree it's a good game
yeah
Summer's summer is very cool
Thurman asked was another indie game
that let you pick between modern 3D
person and fixed camera angles
did they
that's crazy I'd love to see how they
did that actually look at you teaching
me things them and us
because I just imagined it would be
difficult to
um yeah to design the level with both
the fixed cameras and the third person
in mind but hey it can be done them and
US did it I'll have to check that out
thanks for letting me know
okay
I will play another little song now if
if you don't mind
um what should I play
I might play
um another upbeat one I might play
rocket girl so if you've been following
me on Twitch or whatever
um so along with Emerald engine I'm also
a musician mainly work with Jamie at
Horizon Productions thank you Jamie
um and we've been making a song well
actually we've made the song now for my
friends next film and it's about his
little daughter going into space and
she's like a rocket girl and it's a
really fun song and my nieces are in it
as well so it sounds really good
um
but yeah I will play that for you now
uh let me just get up the lyrics just in
case I forget them
[Music]
hi I wanna fly
past the clouds in the blue sky I won't
stop till I reach the Stars
let's go to Mass
[Music]
so far away
is
[Music]
yeah
she'll be okay
I'm on a journey to find my place
[Music]
I say hello to the Moon
you're not okay
I'm on a journey to find my place
as I touch down
on tonight
part of me will
always
[Music]
before
now I have flown
past the moon to the unknown
no matter
how far away from
my places
home
[Music]
rocket girl that's that song you can
listen up for that uh that will be
coming out I don't know maybe the end of
this year missing we're staying with Kai
we're gonna make another music video for
it exciting thank you for listening
and thank you dog of man I've just seen
your message you might not still be here
but congrats on 50K I've only got 10
minutes here you might not be here but
enjoy the rest of your stream I hope
you're not watching dog of man today
nice chord progression well mate thank
you very much Leon thank you everyone
and like how Maria is very excited to
see the ukulele coming out
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you
wow
wow wow
[Music]
coming soon coming soon to the internet
near you if the Internet isn't okay no
it is because because you're here
not soon enough
should have called it Astro girl Astro
girl
why it's rocket guy well that is
actually the name of the film so
um yes the music video involves yeah
it's getting on an actual rocket space
how did you know
[Music]
um have you been in touch with Elon I
told him not to tell anyone
oh dear funny funny
okay I think I should probably stop
postponing it we should probably watch
this first YouTube video what do you
think
and then maybe answer a few more
questions after that
yes I think we should do that
so um of course we don't have to but I
just thought it'd be interesting to see
how far I've come and look at me go
um
image the rock version Oh imagine the
world rocket girl and just everyone's
screaming you can try and do like some
some growling
no I don't think I can do that I
couldn't I couldn't not think about
rocket from guardians when I was
listening to the lyrics
that's cute I thought you were live on
Twitch LOL
I'm on YouTube today we're celebrating
50K
150k exciting
and I also want to say a massive thank
you to everyone who like I've worked
with over the years so that's like Jacob
Jamie Braden Nina even all these people
that I've worked with who have helped me
like edit videos and you know make me
well support me as well but also just
yeah help me uh with my music and things
so thank you so much
yag is why the company is called SpaceX
oh
yes
I like this keep it going
and keep it going
um okay well let me get up this video
and we can
we can have some LOLs even the first
frame I'm like why
they look at me I'm wearing eyeliner
I've gotten so much better eyeliner
so what I have to say okay
shout out to them
that's me thanks that is you Jamie
that's you Jamie your turbo is in
positions
the X stands for explosion
I I explode every day
okay let's go into are you ready for
this jump scare
three
two
one
jump scare what
look at me what the hell who is she
what is that straightened hair
what is that
really well I'm gonna guess just I just
didn't really put on much makeup to be
fair back then
okay let's watch this together
um
actually hold on I'll watch it through
my headphones so I'll just get that
sorted
American Girl
[Music]
I really appreciate that thank you so
much for your super chats
it's so lovely of you means a lot
[Music]
thank you so much
and donated five euros through Super
Chat congratulations
thank you very much much appreciated
okay let's get back on the baby meme
couldn't grants on the subs thank you so
much Carlos are you gonna stick with us
while we watch a Rudy awkward video
uh okay
all right I can see them I can see you I
can see you tapping I see you reacting
I'll see you tapping and your reactants
and you're making lots of Hudson
confetti go on the screen
doesn't really work out does it hey
Jamie Gordon thank you so much for your
congratulations
should we watch the Octodad video too oh
my gosh fine we can watch the Octodad
video too
who's that girl looks like someone with
a bright future here on YouTube thanks
Leah look at you I see you tapping and
reacting
okay all right kudos to YouTube that's
actually a pretty fun feature I like
that
okay are we ready
no if I'm ready okay screw it let's just
do it
oh the Edison
so how long was I there the lighting
completely changed
oh beeps I mean I don't even watch
television anymore I literally YouTube
don't watch TV at all how do you start
your very own yeah stop trying to get me
to pay for TV license what most of us do
is we put YouTube videos how to
successfully get started on YouTube look
at tutorials we read about it how do you
do a YouTube videos
and most of us don't even get around to
making that first video
it feels a bit too nervous or too
awkward
the I hate the the white noise it's
annoying my name is Yasmin also known as
yagman but my friends
house which is pretty creepy because
they could be listening right now on us
I was living with eight other people
so even that tiny but compared to this
it really is
yes the amount of cuts
why should you be mean to make a vlog or
you know unless you only have one hobby
which is fair enough you can have one of
them but I have a lot of people I still
have a lot of hobbies oh my God stop
it's disgusting abandoned buildings
so it I'm just gonna make
videos of whatever
well I feel like it I was way more Janna
back then actually this is very awkward
whatever
I'll get over that
it's hard it's what you've ever made a
video before
oh God
[Music]
for very much longer because I have a
big ass building from my window
I don't even have the right stands so
I've just got
this this is my son
[Music]
just be yourself cute
make everything okay it's what I've
heard
so
yeah how do you end why do I keep
changing the
right oh yeah I suppose I'll just see
what happens
bye oh my God so awkward what the hell I
hope this makes you realize that if I
can make a video so can you
know that I have no friends I didn't
have any friends I probably shouldn't
tell
wow okay so there we go first YouTube
video
as you can see
it took me a long time to get
comfortable in front of the camera I'm
basically I'm whispering there like this
um um I have a lot of hobbies
I was awkward as also like I said I
was living in a house show with like
eight other people and I'd only just
moved in so I think also that that you
know I wasn't in a very comfortable
living situation but look how I've got
editing skills 10 out of 10 oh yeah so I
was a natural editor
what did I use iMovie that was it iMovie
free
and I was just like having fun with all
of the little
iMovie edits oh my gosh uh it was
amazing wimpy girl is like you he
he no friends just housemates no they
weren't they yeah I mean they weren't
friends so yeah a part
ner and then I made friends with Laura
and then I had one friend and it was
great but yeah that oh my God London
just so many bad memories of London but
yeah that was me when I started so I've
got it public still
no this is like when your parents bring
out the photo album and you're like no
oh my God yeah like you
were shooting these little pants you
remember they were your favorite Parts
you wouldn't leave the house without
these pants and you're like shut up
it's amazing I don't remember the pants
mum
um but yeah what am I saying I don't
know
if I can do it so can you it's basically
what I'm saying I meet a lot of people
and they go how are you so uncomfortable
in front of the camera and I say well
I've just been doing it for 10 years
so um yeah definitely took like a long
time for me to get comfortable in front
of the camera
uh and I I think most people do I think
for some people it probably takes longer
than others to get comfortable in front
of the camera but yeah it's uh it's
something you work on it really is a
skill
um hey Steph
what initially thank you for the
congratulations Steph what initially
inspired you to make that video in the
first place were you trying to inspire
people in particular so um good question
um
I like I said I just moved to London I
had no friends I had like nothing to do
on the weekends because I was also on a
very low wage so I couldn't really
afford to do anything and I've just been
like I said there watching YouTube for
like a long time and I felt really
lonely honestly I'd moved to like this
new city on my own I felt really lonely
and the only people I felt
stop that loneliness was YouTubers
um sounds like so awkward not in like um
you know I didn't think I was their
friends or anything kind of way but I
just realized if they help me just by
filling in my
silence you know then maybe I could do
the same for other people and it would
give me something to do
because I was learning to be a web
developer in an advertising agency but I
was really into film and um I did like
filming college and stuff so I was like
well I could still record edit
um do all of these things in my spare
time if I had a YouTube video and it
would also stop me feeling so lonely and
sad on the weekends so it was like a
little bit of that so honestly I didn't
do it for any other reason than to a
like work on my skills as a video
videographer I guess
um
fill up this the spare time and just be
creative I wasn't really
I thought it would be cool if I could
Inspire other people but I literally did
not think it was going to reach anyone I
just thought it was going to help me
just doesn't make sense I thought if I
could reach like 30 people that would be
really cool I probably have some videos
here of me actually being like thank you
but yeah it's interesting looking back
at that because like I said I have so
many hobbies and I didn't know I was
like I don't know what kind of YouTuber
I want to be and I feel like that has
been my whole entire life and career on
YouTube I've always kind of just done a
little bit of stuff and now I'm finally
finding a niche like 10 years later so
it just goes to show it takes a while
um it can pay off though but it does it
does take a while
and still to this day I'm still like no
you can't put me in a box I don't belong
there
[Music]
um
I found that London is especially
challenging in terms of meeting new
people yeah which struck me as well for
being such a big city no so what I found
is the bigger the city The More Lonely
it is because you would you would think
it'd be the other way because there's
more people but the more people the less
people want to interact and trust one
another if you have smaller people
you're easier it's so much easier to
make connections just trust one another
to create a trusting environment and
Community as soon as it gets really big
it just gets
people just don't talk to each other
it's like if you go to like a small town
or Village in the countryside and go for
a walk people will say hello good
morning good afternoon whatever
if you go out for a walk in London
people will be shoving past you because
they've got to be somewhere you know
um
so yeah it's very different vibe
although I think I think Brighton's a
nice little nice little in between it's
not as uh as a
as busy and as
ah as lonely as London but that is also
just my experience of London because
like I said I also I was on 800 pound a
month so I couldn't go out and do social
things or like meet people socially so I
think if you had the money then perhaps
you would
um
have a different experience
or if you are born there you know and
you you get to grow up with the city and
with people but if when you move it's
yeah it's a lot it's a lot but it's it's
very
it's very life-changing it definitely
shapes you as a person
it shapes you
um I just moved to Perth today from
Singapore how was it like to move well
congratulations on your move I know it's
really stressful isn't it
um Leo Louis I'm sorry if I'm picturing
names again
um but congratulations on showing me
because I know it's really scary and I
know it's um especially if you're moving
on your own or or even just with a
couple of people like you're moving away
from whoever was back in your old place
um so how was my move it was
so exciting but very like yeah
intimidating because it's just like
living in a house with like a bunch of
people that you don't know and honestly
in London it's just awful there it's
really bad in London like
I had to move houses every three to six
months because houses would have
problems or start falling apart or I
mean I lived with a drug dealer once
that actually
did some bad stuff and I had to move out
so like
yeah just London needs to sort its
out and just become more affordable
because it's ridiculous
um but I think the yeah the hardest
thing about moving is just just getting
used to all the new things but also it's
kind of exciting too right it's nice to
be like oh new chapter in my life so
yeah best of luck to you
uh
so you want to watch Octodad is that
what you want to do you want to watch
the Octodad video I guess
we're here now watching old videos so I
might as well
golly gosh but yeah I thought I would
keep that video public because I want
people to if they ever look at me and go
like wow she's so good on camera blah
blah blah I could never then they could
like go back in my videos and be like
hmm I wonder if what her first video is
like and then just see that and go Ah
that's more like what I can do and they
were okay if that's how she started and
now she's here then maybe I could do do
it too so I think it's a good idea to
keep up your first video unless it's
something that you absolutely hate I
think it's good crime stories with yag
man one day maybe I'll do a London tell
all of all of my a London story time
that would not fit with my channel now
would it let's do Game Dev and I'll do a
story Game Dev Story time they do have
um artist Story Time people don't they
where they do art like they draw and
then they tell you a story I could just
gain Dev and tell you a story I don't
think I could do that though because I
need to think about
yeah
like code and I'd be like anyway I
was in London and then oh do I need a
booty in here or should I use a maybe I
should just use an integer and then and
then I'd like get confused and to not be
able to do both things
girls on hitting 50
. much aotl tin
thank you so much yes Octodad okay I
hear you Michael I hear you and uh if
anyone has any more questions feel free
to drop them in the chat and I'll answer
them in a little moment
but um
yeah let's find
where is Octodad well I've done so many
stupid videos
I've put a lot of them as unlisted
actually because they were just
awfully
embarrassing and I don't even know why I
made them it was very obvious when I
started my Channel that I was doing it
for myself and myself only
here we go Octodad dance
amazing I think this is still yeah this
is still public so you can watch it as
many times as you want Michael
I'm sure you have
oh geez
I look so strange
okay are you ready for this
was when was that must have been almost
10 years
um nine years ago it's Octodad yeah
oh dear dear dear
okay right let's do this
um okay
[Music]
I lose that lose
why did I have this idea
[Music]
all right
wow
there we go
now I can't monetize this stream
oh geez Louise
don't worry yeah you got better thanks
dick
oh my gosh another London moment oh yes
how long was that there I think I lived
there for two years
I admire your confidence thank you so do
I I don't know how the hell
I think when the camera comes out I
become a different person I honestly
think that's what happens to me
oh my gosh
yeah that city is definitely yes it's
certainly London it's certainly London
who was waking the camera good question
Jamie that actually was uh Jamila
um Maisha Jamila she is the biggest
YouTuber now in the Netherlands
I'm always like how how I
I messaged her one day because she had
um a channel called DX Dutch and she was
um singing on that channel beautiful
voice which is a lovely person and I
messaged her and I was like oh my gosh I
love your videos I'm just starting out
on YouTube if you have any tips but like
don't worry if not I completely
understand and um she was so nice to me
and she replied to me and she gave me
loads of tips and then we just ended up
being friends and even today we message
and yeah she came to visit me in London
it's crazy crazy times that's one good
thing about YouTube as well you meet a
lot of nice people here
um and a lot of like-minded creative
individuals which is very nice
as well
um so yeah now she's all famous and
she's super famous she's in like films
and she's like she's like touring with
her songs but she totally deserves it
because she fits in so much hard work
and I think she's like oh just such a
lovely person I love my sugar Mila we
love Jamila
you did the pumpkin carving with her
yeah I went to Texas to visit her a long
long time ago hey unusually
it's now I hadn't read your questions
because I was waiting for you to come
I'm here stream can start now
hi cutie pie congratulations on 50K you
deserve every sub you also always work
so hard on my G that octodar video
that's the energy I aspired to have
oh golly gosh thank you so much unusual
simpler times absolutely I was looking
at funny gameplay and came across your
video for the first time yes used to do
so many gameplay videos I do still do
some gameplay by the way but it's mainly
just on Twitch um so if you do miss
those check out gaming with the agman X
on YouTube or just follow me on Twitch
and uh you can watch me scream in real
time which is fun
only when we're playing horror games of
course I mean you might also catch me
cry if we play an emotional game I'm a
very emotional person very emotional gal
um go go Jamila yeah exactly
uh okay so now that unusual illusion is
here I'm going to answer unusual
Illusions questions that they have for
me so one second
um
if anyone else has questions as well
feel free to ask them and I'm sure I'll
get around to answering so unusual
Illusions questions
um they left them in the Discord was
if you could get 50k people together in
real life to do something fun fun what
would you get everyone to do
oh gosh
um
is money an option
if money isn't an option I would
honestly just do like a tanacon thing
but for me I I would hopefully not
um
I'd probably make mistakes but hopefully
I wouldn't I would at least have enough
people to come into the venue
um but I would love to do something like
that
to do like
I want to like have a whole event where
it's like music and video games and just
interactive art and stuff like that and
um I could just make it like a whole I
don't know like an interactive thing
um give everyone
Bluetooth bracelets or um what's the
other type of blueprint it's not I want
to say nft but that's not the right word
uh it's basically longer range than
Bluetooth
um they use it in
um Disney and stuff like in the Harry
Potter world and the Mario World and you
touch things but anyway and um maybe you
could like make things happen there and
I want to have places where people can
sing and get up on stage and and uh
booths where people can show off their
games or their like technical Creations
basically it's just a big event where we
can just all be like hey we are creative
and this is what we do like that would
be really fun I would love that and I
would love to sing on stage for you as
well and watch all of you do whatever
you want to do like on stage or at
booths and just like yeah just a Yaz
Khan exactly and is your illusion just a
yazcon just see what everyone's doing
an interactive gag my experience is out
of her mind yeah so like yes I will be
inviting you to my mind in real life
that'd be great I would
love that and then I would also invite
you to invite me into your brain by
offering like booths and stuff for you
to show all your things RFID tips I
think you meant that's how Disney does
the HP ones I think oh yes probably
something like that yeah
but that would be so cool
that would be like those staircases
going every which way
and um they have more questions will you
forget us now you're famous silly I'm
not even famous
but now of course of course not like
even if I did get famous which it's not
happening by the way
um
you are the reason for it you know like
you're the reason why we have 50k
subscribers so uh why would I ever
forget you and if I do bunk'd be on the
head or just do something to be like you
are becoming entitled stop because I'd
hate I'd hate for that to happen but
hopefully that will never happen
because I think one thing about being an
online creator
is most of the time it keeps you humble
because without the people who watch you
you're nothing so oh my God no that
sounds really bad no I'll take that back
I take that back that's a negative way
of thinking
you're not nothing you're someone you're
a person you're a very you know
important to different people in
different ways and your worth is not
your work or your social output look
look at me trying to dig myself out of a
hole that I just jumped into
um I mean that your YouTube channel and
like your Fame I guess is is
like not going to be sustainable and not
going to even exist if you don't have
the support of people like you and I
think
if you don't show that you're grateful
for that support then
I don't know I don't know I'm going with
this
short answer no I'm not gonna forget you
because you're a massive part of this
Channel and that's what makes YouTubers
YouTubers is that it's not just one
person it is everyone everyone involved
the the people who comment the people
who like the people who watch because
also you know without that the algorithm
is never going to watch the videos or
see the videos or put out the videos so
you need engagement
um and that's yeah so
I mean I'm getting very technical here
now aren't I na mate I'm not gonna
forget you don't worry about it there
you go that's my answer
that's my answer
um can you think of any comments people
have left on videos that stood out to
you
and you may left a little heart so this
is a lovely lovely question
um I will say for YouTubers
the negative comments stick out the more
like the most which just sucks I just
think that's how it goes with most
people right like it's not just a
YouTuber thing it's probably just like a
person thing like if if someone says
something to you negative in a day or a
week you're probably gonna remember that
first then
any other
um any other nice comments so I can
probably tell you like bad comments that
I remember uh because I read them and I
go like oh no you know it makes me feel
sad and I'm like oh no maybe I'm
maybe I should give up maybe you should
quit but
um the good comments I can't remember
any specifically on YouTube but honestly
it's it's well I remember like I
literally got one I think yesterday
um that I need to respond to but it's
just when when people open up about
their lives to me that's what gets me
the most and that's the ones that I
remember the most like the ones who
say and to be fair this happens on
YouTube a lot where they say I
have been really trying to understand
this
learn Game Dev or whatever it is and
this video helped me do that obviously
that makes me feel really happy
um but especially when they take it one
step further and they they like maybe DM
me or like send something to me
personally
and they say like things like they've
been struggling or they sometimes lose
sight of why they love to create in the
first place right and then they they say
that my channel is like a breath of
fresh air to them they come there
because it it reminds them of like what
the fun is in creating and it doesn't
always have to be corporate because once
you start to do something as a job you
start to just see it as a corporate
thing and a completely understand that
um so whenever I hear anyone say that
like say that that my videos help them
in an emotional way
um that's the ones that stick with me
personally so yeah it's those ones
you're the reason for the 50k being the
reason that Nan's cute Nikki thank thank
you you deserve the success thank you
Nana thank you everyone you're so
freaking lovely yeah like I say every
year I'd love to persist it in a game
Jam hosted by you imagine the amounts of
cute games we could create yes that
would take a lot of time on on my side
but I would love to one day Carlos I
totally agree I would love to do that
and maybe one day
um I mean the channel is growing so
maybe one day I could dedicate more time
to this you know maybe make it like
sustain me somehow
um and uh yeah I could do something like
that for you because that would be great
and I'm trying my darndest I'm trying my
darndest I'm offering way more perks on
patreon and everything so we'll see we
shall see we'll see how it goes
but I appreciate all the support
um
and uh there's more questions what's
your favorite thing about helping teach
people new skills
on them
um
[Music]
I just think I just think it should be
accessible to everyone I think what
annoys me or this doesn't annoy me but
what I see in especially technical
fields
is uh that I think people become very
good at what they do and then they
forget
the small hurdles of being a beginner
and I think that's what I pride myself
in I try not to forget those small
hurdles maybe it's because I will always
be a beginner I don't know maybe I'm
just never gonna be good but that's fine
because
I remember like what I struggle with or
what I struggled with uh and a lot of
that is like terminology and
um
explanations like why
if you teach someone oh uh or turn off
tick that's in performance
why and then you're scared can I use
tick when am I allowed to use tick
should I never use tick oh my God and um
so that's why I I think it's nice to
teach people in a way that's like a fun
because making games being creative
doing whatever it should be fun right
it's not always gonna be fun but I think
if you want to get into it there should
be some semblance of fun there so fun
um B Be beginner friendly and just
accessible and see
um allow someone to then go away with
the knowledge to then expand upon what
they've just learned
and whenever I do a tutorial video I
always learn at the same time so I love
that because I I tend to learn more
there's some sometimes I'll do a shower
video and I'll be like oh yeah I'm gonna
just do this now and then I think to
myself wait I should probably explain
why I'm doing that and then I think I
don't know why I do that and I I
actually realize I've got habits that I
do that I don't even know why I do it I
just know it's good practice so anyway
I'm rambling again
just answer the question I don't even
know I just that that making Game Dev
more accessible there you go bite size
answer
um I might be late to the stream okay
yeah that was the last question and
there you go you got your answers I hope
you liked them congrats on 50K thank you
so much VR division Miko go to gaming
with yagman X or twitch
twitch that's where you can watch a
wimpy girl because unfortunately I won't
be doing any game play videos on this
channel anymore but if you search gaming
with the Ackman X or just watch me on
Twitch then you will see me screaming
live which is very fun
best way to learn is to teach I can
attest to that personally absolutely
ranith you are so right yes I think
because even once you start doing
something for a long time you can still
obviously be very good at what you do
but you just forget little things like
why do you do this and um yeah I think
teaching and breaking things down
definitely allows you to to learn more
yourself
I did that was very interesting thank
you you are very welcome unusual
illusion very welcome
oh okie dokie thank you
okay should we do another
um hey I got the follow thank you for
the follow on my twitch uh shall we do
another song yeah let's do another song
um maybe I'll get my guitar this time it
is there staring at us it's very
beautiful isn't it it's very beautiful
guitar
for gameplay what genres oh we have we
have another question okay one sec what
other genres of games and music you've
uh you haven't gotten enough experience
with but might want to delve into
hmm
that's a good question
um
[Music]
gosh
um
okay so I think this question might be a
bit too broad because I would argue that
you could do any genre of game or music
but there's just technicalities that you
might struggle with if if you're not
if you don't know something so I'm not
very good musically I'm not very good
with many of my instruments but I play
it because I love writing and I love
singing
um I don't know if there's like a genre
of music uh maybe more rock because like
I yeah I like rock music but uh I I
can't play like
um you know really good electric guitar
and I can't scream or anything but I
don't know if I would actually want to
do that but it's really fun to do and
then I get to do that with Jamie which
is great so Jamie fulfills that for me
um and then with games I mean
I would say multiplayer but then that's
what I do in my day job so I am working
on a multiplayer game online
um but I don't think I'd want to do that
in my
free time because
it's it adds a lot of layers of
complication to things
I think because I do it in my day job
I'd like to not do it in my
free time and just working like a single
player offline game that would just be
like heaven
um but genre
I mean
I don't know I guess
I
the genres that I don't feel like I have
the skills to make are also the genres
that I am not interested in and that's
why I don't have the skills to make them
does that make sense
because the genres I'm interested in
I've already started to build up the
skills that I would need to make those
genres such as like horror games and
narratively driven games because that's
what I'm really interested in so
um that's what the skills like uh like
of writing and scripting and
um you know all of this stuff
uh affords for that
um but maybe not more not so much for
like a racing game or like a shooting
game like Call of Duty
um but then again I wouldn't want to
make one of those games so you've you've
opened up many doors on my head now like
I hope I answered that I don't know I
don't know
um but of course there are many things
I'm not good at but I also think I love
her I love a challenge so if I
wanted to do something I'm just gonna
try it you know even if I fail I think
that's a good way to be
um just be like I wanted to buy it even
if I fail uh yeah
thank you
most Vlog isn't screaming to be fair
I love rock but when it gets heavy
enough they're just screaming I dip I
like I like I guess like kind of like
slip knot or something where they'll
scream for a little bit and they'll
start singing and then go back to
screaming and singing but I mean I
wouldn't be able to play
um the musical instruments because
especially in like I don't know like
heavy metal or something it's like
[Music]
and I can hardly do yeah yeah yeah
so so yeah
hey Bruce have you ever seen a horror
stage play like oh my gosh no I haven't
but I would love to like the woman in
black or have or wait oh and have or
would you ever like to perform on stage
ah I like this question also have slash
would you make an unreal game with a
fixed location
uh wait with a fixed location do you
mean fixed fixed camera
um so yeah funny you should say I used
to be in the theater when I was a kid
and I guess that's where like a lot of
this comes from as well because I loved
acting loved it loved singing I've
always loved singing on stage
um I was like I I was singing on stage
when I was in like Primary School
uh I was also acting in primary school I
used to be in a local theater group uh
so yeah I freaking loved it I was baby
June so I oh my gosh I'll have to try
and dig out the videos actually maybe we
can I'll use it for a music video or
something sometime there's a little baby
me I must be like 10 11 or something
maybe even younger and I've got really
curly hair and I just go like hello
everybody my
what's
what's you let me let me change you I
don't know yeah it's very dramatic and
Theatrical but yeah I used to love the
theater like so much
um
still miss it now to be honest I'm
always like oh that was a fun time in my
life but yeah but I I've been to the
theater before
um I like I like seeing theater things
but I haven't seen a horror in the
theater and I would love that yeah to
see like the woman in black in the
theater that would be really really cool
have you watched it do you know do you
know much about it I think I remember
someone saying that
there's like a woman stands up in the
audience or something and it's really
unnerving because they've been sat there
the whole time I could be making this
up but uh I believe something like
that happens and it sounds really really
cool
the ghost stories play is also very
entertaining oh I didn't even know that
was a thing
this is why I love talking to you online
so much from you ghost stories play
because I have the wait is this based
off the book hold on let me get the let
me get a book out is this based off this
book
um
no it's not
oh no it's not I've got this book and
it's called um scary stories to tell in
the dark and I thought I thought it
might be based off that because these
books are really cool they've got
they're basically filled with like old
spooky stories that used to get told
through generations and like how I said
with my friend when I was a kid used to
just tell
me and my little brother scary stories
this is kind of like that I miss that I
feel like we used to be way more
creative back in the day because we
didn't have TV or anything everyone's
used to sit around telling each other
stories I want to do that again
um but anyway maybe I will maybe I
well anyway
oh guitar
yes it's psychological and it's so much
about sound the props I saw on the stage
play were really simple but the sounds
coming out of the speakers and the
acting really took you there but you're
still half in the theater it's like old
style augmented oh wow that sounds
really interesting yes okay I would love
to see women in black
I love women in black I'm a girl
so Susanna it's another fan yeah so I
would definitely like that musical
theater kid yeah yeah basically it was
part of my guides group actually more
brownies and guides
did you do it in January no I did it in
like stupid American accent
not saying American accents are stupid
another whole I've just dug myself in I
meant my American accent was stupid
um
oh my gosh so funny
but you're still in the theater it's
like the old oh yeah you already said
that I love the bit with the candle on
the hand
I need to go and see this theater show
now I am intrigued call me intrigued
because I am
let me play a song what song should I
play
um pirate shanty
um
failure or deserve more
[Music]
I could play this one
yeah I'll pick this one
hi intrigued oh my gosh
and usually
[Music]
okay so this is a song called
um deserve more
and
it'll be on the next DP whenever that
comes out
so yeah
hope you'll like it
[Music]
uh you missed rocket girl unfortunately
unusual illusion
[Music]
oh
everything you wanted
does it match up to
what you saw everything you needed
everything you worked so hard for you
might have your money but
go
just can't keep you warm see the stress
and the late nights
you pushed away I could be yours
you deserve more
[Music]
everything I wanted
everything that burns at my core
everything I
needed
everything I stifle
I don't have much money but
I have something worth so much more a
future to cross
is it that one grass
if your hand will unclasp
don't I deserve more
more
and everything we've wanted
I know it has changed from before
in our mind you planted
a vision of a life we can't afford we'll
waste all our money on what you have
shown real molded as our own and fill us
with flowers
[Music]
did you seize every moment
was it your choice you made
to a place those who care
did I
die that glass
judgment Keeps Us tame
to replace our dreams
something far more
[Music]
Monday
we deserve
d
[Music]
there you go
I am so looking forward to getting that
song finished and recorded with Jamie
for you because I think it's probably my
favorite song that I've written
um so yeah I hope you enjoyed that
little song I saw your hearts I saw your
giving hearts so thank you very much for
those
everything I stifle for the core oh for
a line
ah thanks unusual illusion and hey
Philly fighter welcome to the Stream
and like her housemate only dope stuff
yags dealts to people what's the EP
hey it's a dope
thank you thank you thank you I
appreciate it
thanks for the serenade you're very
welcome Michael Mikko Michael
Mikko hey Benny thank you for the claps
I should have like a a cheering thing
but I I don't so we'll just we'll just
um we'll just make do with this
wow
amazing
thank you so much
okay do we have any more questions that
you might want to ask or should I just
keep on playing you some songs
100 is that 100 out of one
uh if so thank you very much intellitron
minus one for being too sweet
um
I need to I need to get some grunge in
there
I'm at work just stopping to Listen by
for a bit okay thank you so coming Billy
I hope your work day is going okay hello
work colleagues unless you work from
home and then hello
empty room
if he sounds for epic of course of
course it does of course it does
I'll just see if there's like any other
old videos that we might want to watch
together
um but yeah feel free if you do have any
more questions to send them over and if
not that's totally cool too because I
can still play some songs and stuff
don't worry I'm a professional
Entertainer this is what I do for a
living
um
gosh I don't think I want to watch any
of these it's so bad I wonder if I have
um a video actually that's like thank
you for 100 subscribers or something
because that'd be cute
oh here we go yeah I do 400 subscribers
was that my first thank you 400
subscribers that's so cute
oh
um oh oh we have questions okay
tippers
um I was going to ask a few things this
is from Billy why did you switch from
Unity to Unreal any reason in particular
Perfection was done in unity are you
making a horror game project in
particular on particular
um yeah so the only reason why I
switched from Unity to Unreal was
because I got a job in the games
industry and they use Unreal Engine as
in the work my work use Unreal Engine so
whenever people ask me like it's
honestly nothing there's no tea
I don't I don't have any like
preference well I guess I do now my
preference is Unreal Engine but that's
only because I know it way more like
Unity has changed a lot since I used it
last I really do miss C sharp though I
will say I miss C sharp but um that is
honestly the only reason so yeah I don't
think it's I didn't jump ship because I
didn't like Unity it was just because it
was beneficial for me to work in Unreal
Engine more so than Unity
uh and I'm you making a horror project
in particular no well yes I'm making a
horror music video if that counts in
Unreal Engine
um and the first video of that will come
out on Monday because I'm going to take
you through the processes of how I make
a music video
um so look out for that
um but yeah
not making a game unfortunately mainly
because
um I make you know I I work in in a
studio now a bigger studio and it's um
I mean
there there is like when you when you
work in a studio you do have to be
careful a little bit about personal
projects because obviously you need to
get sign up and staff
um but also it's just it does take off
it takes a lot of time and energy and
then because I want to keep doing
YouTube as well so um maybe one day it
would be nice to make another game it
would be nice to progress on the ideas
that I dabbled with imperfection
um because I still think there's some
ideas that I haven't seen elsewhere and
I'm like oh I'd love to flesh them out
um but yeah we shall see
uh in terms of Music would you ever want
to do a venue gig or even touring yes
Moscato I absolutely would I really miss
singing live so I'm trying to find more
time to practice it more often hence why
I would do it on the streams
um to a get more confident and B just
just build back up the calluses on my
fingers and also just the memory of the
songs
um because I freaking love it but I'm
gonna start small and just go to Open
Mic nights around my area and then we
shall see maybe one day I could do
something and be like hey I'm playing
here everyone come see me that that will
be fun but I don't know and I'm just
gonna take it step by step
Nikki first live stream maybe were you
nervous
of my first live stream
play yeah I can't remember it's so long
ago so long ago I cannot remember but I
probably was absolutely terrified I
think I remember I did it on my laptop
and I think I was oh no I used a
periscope does anyone remember Periscope
does a long time ago I used to Periscope
I used to sing on Periscope almost every
night
um yeah that was fun that was different
but I think that felt different it
didn't feel as like
um as professional I guess because it
was just on my phone and I just like
prop it up on my laptop and just sing
sitting on my bed
um so but yeah I I was nervous I was
nervous of course
what's your favorite accent voice to do
and which do you find the hardest oh my
gosh Bruce
uh I love doing like a Northern or an
Irish accent even though I suck I know I
suck but I I find it really fun to do
um and the ones I find the hardest
I actually really struggle with
Australian which is weird because people
think that I oh I've had people think I
was Australian before and I don't
understand how because I can't even do
an Australian accent if I tried uh I
can't do many accents to be fair
um but yeah honestly I'm not very good
with accents at all so not many
um not YouTube related but if you had to
be either one foot tall or ten foot tall
which is your fake oh my gosh uh could I
have wings if I'm one foot tall because
if so I'll just I'll just have that I'll
just be a fairy
um I like being short I'm used to being
sure I don't know how 10 foot would feel
you literally could not hide anyway
could you but then if you're short you
you you'd be hidden all the time even
when you didn't want to be like hello
hello I would like to buy some
[Music]
sauce um but then that one sausage roll
would last you like a whole month
because you're so tiny you got a tiny
belly
be good for this cost of living crisis
we are currently in in England
hmm
up north exactly Moscato oh yeah I like
the northern
it's funny
uh when you said you had to get sign off
to work to on your own game what do you
mean uh using work pieces for prep no no
God no no you don't use wet PCS um
unusually it's just if you work in like
um I've always had it like in in
advertising and stuff as well if you're
working in a in a company a big big
company and organization
um they want to make sure that you're
not also racking on something that could
conflict with um their interests so
usually you have to like um
let your employee know like what you're
doing on the side if you have any other
forms of income
um it's it's mainly just to save their
own skin like just in case you're going
to be
um using their information elsewhere you
know something like that it's just it's
just politics it's just company politics
I remember the periscopes yes I know you
do Jamie that's how you found me wasn't
it you like movies hit here I like
movies I like movies
I like movies uh what did I watch I
don't know I've watched movies
I've watched many movies I like the
movies the hereditary is great
um
I like movies
I like uh I like FernGully fungal is a
good film
hey Tom what's up
I think being 10 foot has its problems
too oh absolutely
you won't be able to hide that's my main
thing like you'd always be everywhere
everyone would see you all the time food
still lasts You Forever Wait would it
why why would it last you forever if you
turn foot you'd get a sausage roll if
you're 10 foot you'd be like
what is this club
also over three meters could be painful
yeah it's not that's very true actually
very true I would not want to have them
grow in pains I didn't have any Growing
Pains growing up because I'm so short
how are you doing Tom so nice to see you
here thank you so much for being here
being over six foot is already hard on
the back it's easy to injure yourself
yes that's why if you're tall do yoga it
helps it helps it really does
hey Mickey pop hello from Chile hi I
hope I hope you're doing well over there
um I get that ones uh would say being a
lawyer scientist but it seems odd when
it comes to creative field now it it's
the same everywhere unfortunately
unusual illusion I do understand it
though I do understand it
why are you so concerned about hiding
what do you need to hide from just
people you know it's like hiding
he's like if someone's taking a picture
and you're just not in the mood you'll
be there no matter if you stand at the
back you'll be there
anyone over six foot you probably get
this problem anyway to be fair
I'm all right lovely I'm glad to hear it
Tom
I always thought being under five foot
would be nice and Devin you couldn't see
over the hedgerows so every time would
be a new discovery such Adventure yeah
that actually happens to me like on a
weekly basis
I'll just be walking around I have no
idea what's going on and then all of a
sudden brain will go wow that Garden's
gorgeous and I'm like what I'm like I
can literally just see what's in front
of me how are you seeing over everyone's
Hedges you creep
but yeah
here fighting against the 2030 agenda do
it I don't know what that means but do
it
yes honey and cupboards and stuff yes
yes I'm very good at hide and seek trust
me trust me I'll hide anyway I'm good at
this stuff
okay should we play another song
play
I'll play the pirate Shanty go on let's
do this so
I'll send you the lyrics
and it you know well if you haven't
watched my streams on Twitch I've done
this a few times now
what happens is icing it through once
and then this this is why I'd love to do
a live show because it was so fun to
sing live and I I see this as a pirate
Shanty so I really want like to hear a
crowd just be like oh jump and say let
it push over me just like sing Never
Been well seeing like scream basically
it would be nice uh but yeah I'll put
the I'll put the lyrics in the chat and
if you want from home you can join me
and uh hopefully no one can hear you so
it doesn't matter you don't need to
worry about how you sound
um
but yeah
I will I'll put them in now I don't know
what the word count is in here actually
so let me have a look
um okay let me put it in
so that's the first bit
grabs rum yeah do it everyone
get your rum
okay
did you learn if I were a fish by kuruk
that song is bad
bloody cute I'm so badly cute those are
badly cute it's a way to be cute badly
fun to play no I don't wait if I were
for sure was it that one
I don't know what that is I'll have to
check it out
oh my God no I know what you're talking
about it is so cute I don't know how to
play it but yes I I love that one
I uh I can't remember how you sing it
but oh yeah it's so cute but yeah we'll
we'll do this one and then such a
violence yes
I know what you're talking about it's a
cute ass song cute ass song
okay
so I'll sing to you once and then I'll
be like your turn and then at home you
can start singing along with me
[Music]
I'll jump in the sea let it wash over me
as I fight with a cold I feel free I
feel both take my body my mind let me
dance with pride as you thought shut my
lips make them weightless Within
yeah
let your waves cradle all of the roads I
ignore let your son deafen meet oh I
dreamed I could be as you push as your
palm I become your rectum with the taste
of the sea I forget how to breathe
foreign
[Music]
let your waves cradle all overboards
ignore let your tongue deafen meet to
all I dreamed I could be as you push as
you pop become your ex doll with the
taste of the sea I forget how to breathe
[Music]
one day
I hope there will be a little piece of
me buried deep in the Sun that you might
understand
and
did you sing did you sing I hope so
thank you for all the love hearts I
appreciate it
we need some dance mats we do I don't
know if YouTube allows like special
emotes do you know like on Twitch you
know I don't know I haven't done a live
stream on YouTube in so long and I
confuzzled I might need to turn on the
um subscription like members thing but I
don't want to do that because I feel bad
because I've already got patreon so I'm
like I don't want to have Matrix members
and patreon because then maybe that's
greedy I don't know
um you sang yes Jamie nice I'm glad you
sang moshing intensifies Circle pit wow
look at you Kim
um
at that final note understand
that was beautiful thank you
yeah it's such a fun song I think it
would be such a fun song to sing live
especially if any of you like it and you
want to sing along there'll be so cute I
had to really enjoy that it would be
nice
I hope that will be okay so I think
we're gonna watch one more embarrassing
video before I say goodbye we've got 10
minutes left
um I think you deserve it because you
know as I said thank you so much to all
of you you made this happen and uh yeah
I just I'm very very grateful so I think
you deserve one more embarrassing moment
of me watching an old video so I hope
you enjoy it I need to practice for the
recording after all very true very true
okay
so where is it I'm just gonna watch an
old video it was actually like two
minutes long where is it gone well I
just say thank you there for 400 Subs
which is so cute
yes you're very far away but if you ever
make it up north to play live please
make sure you tell me
if I ever go anywhere to sing I'll make
sure that I put it as many places as
possible so hopefully you can all see
don't you worry don't you worry
okay
oh golly gosh this one again
I did a little throwback by the looks of
it anyway
let's oh geez
let's um I'll put this one back for the
time ban
and put on my headphones let's watch
this little video together
[Music]
on my baseball's top I forgot about that
I used to wear that all the time okay
yeah let's just do this
hello hi
I'm kind of overwhelmed at the moment
just because a lot there are so many of
you thank you so much for stopping by
freaking me out and stuff I'm a bit
overwhelmed I'm not gonna lie and at the
same time I'm extremely extremely
grateful more grateful than overwhelming
I just want to say thank you for coming
and watching my videos and
subscribing because you like me but I
don't know what to say just thank you
for stopping by thank you for yeah like
liking me so what I would like to do for
you guys I thought it was about time
what I would love to do is do like a
little q a oh my God I know it's so
boring I've been getting so many
questions on my Twitter on my Tumblr and
Tom would love to answer you all but I
don't see the point of doing it to
individual people when I get asked the
same questions especially how old are
you so yeah I will answer that in the Q
a I would also love to get to know you I
want you guys to know who you're
watching the person behind the camera
and I would also like to know who you
are I'm quite interested in all of you
lovely people ask me questions just any
question that you want to ask they can
be as crazy as you want what dinosaur is
your favorite that's not even that crazy
if you were a cat what part of your body
oh my God it just like ramble and then
that's not that crazy that's obviously
I'm not gonna answer some questions
good super personal but I don't mind
getting a little bit personal for you
guys because I really do want you to
know who I am ask me those questions
through comment section down below or
Twitter Tumblr Facebook I've got all of
my links down there so just have a
gander in return I would like you to
also comment to read this message to my
questions
a little bit more about you guys what
was your favorite childhood game what
motivates you and do you have a role
model and if so who are they or what are
they because it could be your dog I
would like to thank all of you guys yeah
it's my little part of the YouTube world
that is so big that it's hard to even
notice that I'm here it's just so lovely
I honestly appreciate every single one
of you it's so lovely that I've got a
community that actually like to comment
as well and that aren't afraid to kind
of leave me messages on Facebook or
through YouTube every now and then
because you are not big I know I'm not
big I quite like that because that means
I really can't appreciate every single
one of you and I have time for you I
just really hope that content that
entertains you and that I can have fun
with as well so I'm looking forward to
hearing your questions and reading your
answers have a lovely day or evening
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
oh bless me and my tiny ass little room
in London
well I mean I was very grateful then and
I'm still very grateful now and I do
want to who is your role model is it
your dog if anyone's role model is their
dog please let me know and I would
completely understand because the dog's
life is like
Top Notch like what do they do they eat
they sleep they get belly rubs they poop
um
yeah I I think that's role model
material
oh my gosh
uh it's not awkward it's so genuine and
nice you always seem so genuine everyone
oh thank you
yeah so it's very it's very
young
and I'm still a little bit awkward I
think but um
it's it's nice I think it's I think it's
really important actually to like make
time to say thank you to to people you
know who help who help this and also
like I said the reason why I started
YouTube Back Then especially back then I
was like quite a lonely person so um it
did mean a lot to me that like people
were watching and like and interacting
it was really confusing and I was like
what the
and even now I'm like still like what
the
whenever my video gets like more than a
thousand views I'm like what the
that's nice I like this thank you I
appreciate
so I've noticed I do accents when I feel
awkward and it's like it's like a coping
message
oh my gosh
it's hard at the end oh yeah
it's obviously some gameplay video that
I did
and dig the hair oh gosh I hate that you
look kind of different yeah well it was
10 years ago or nine years ago
um just a long time ago it was a long
long time ago
hello sir
I looked quite different sir I know I
did
question three me obviously
what are you answering my questions wait
let me see
question wait what was it question one
question one question one possibly
Pokemon and Cranford oh crunch where's
my four hmm good cool good cool I used
to be a grand tourism against my dad
when I was a kid
um question two maybe Vengeance and the
regrets of my enemies love it how many
enemies have you got damn I haven't had
belly rubs in ages at all
oh I guess you could give them yourself
but it's not the same I understand it
doesn't feel the same it's not the same
um present yags laughing on the dog joke
of past yags must mean something
stupid me stupid me still laughing at
the same stupid things mentioning tumbo
tumble Tumblr what's the stand I know I
was like I'm getting loads of comments
on my Tumblr Tumblr
I forgot I had a Tumblr to be honest
with you
yes you're a very intelligent open funny
interesting and interesting impressing
congratulations on your first
50k and here's to the next 50k thank you
so much I really appreciate that
yeah and thank you so much for spending
um just a couple of hours to celebrate
it with me I really really appreciate it
and as I said earlier as well thank you
so much to everyone who helped make this
a reality to Jamie in the chat right now
um for helping bring my music to a whole
new level like I appreciate that
literally makes my dreams come true I
used to want to make music when I was a
kid and now I'm like oh yeah I'm doing
it that's cool yay and um
also to Jacob who edits some of my
videos whenever I can afford to pay him
and Nina who has done that in the past
as well like all these like amazing
creative people who I've gotten to work
with and of course Brayden who is
actually working with me on my next
music video and of course the song for
that music video was produced by our
very own Jamie in the chat so yeah just
thank you so much to everyone who's
helped make this Channel and everything
that I do here like a reality and of
course
thank you to you yeah you I'm looking at
you for for watching and interacting and
and whatever like even if you don't
comment or anything like just you being
here and watching means a lot and I
really hope that the videos can
um
have a positive
influence in one way or another
yeah it's more flattery please
confetti again you're gonna have to
clean that lady you know that right yeah
don't worry I'll just uh I'm just
hoovering up
it's funny that none of it's landed back
there though isn't it isn't it hooray
for Jamie yeah hooray for Jamie
uh a well for Jamie
oh so funny
um
okay so I'm gonna finish off with a song
and I think probably what better song to
finish off with than sweater eh the
first song that's uh Jamie and I racked
on was it was that the first I think it
was the first song
um so yeah I'm gonna finish off a
sweater and uh
so
um
[Music]
okay
and if you know the song please sing
along at home
[Music]
this was the first song that I ever
wrote exciting
I can't wait forever I know that patient
I got too many things to do your comfy
like a sweater
when the sun comes out I won't be
needing you
[Music]
it's now conceals a secret and it's a
sickly sweet that I can't see the point
of taking deeper and through a surface
side it's just so beautiful
I don't wanna spoil yourself
don't leave this to go
your eyes make me feel dizzy when you
quiz me on my childhood history I'll
share with you if you so kindly cut me
also I can't see
I don't wanna
[Music]
um yeah
uh I could cry through the cracks
[Music]
but instead I enjoy this
time so shallowly
[Music]
I don't wanna spoil my songs
please don't leave us
the best things
[Music]
you
there you go it's the last song for you
thank you so much forgetting my lyrics I
know I'm a poop head sorry uh congrats
for 50k subscribers thank you so much
and teletron X you already sounded
present oh thank you you're very kind
person lots of love from Nepal I'm gonna
I'm a GTG well thank you so much I
really appreciate that means so so much
to me uh and thank you Mr Fahrenheit as
well I can see all your little hearts so
thank you so much for those
um
uh understandable yeah I get so like I'm
like singing and then I'm like oh the
chat and I'm like what the am
I singing again
oh dear uh I'll just have to do it more
and get more used to it
um but yeah thank you so much for coming
I really appreciate you being here uh if
you like this format if you like live
streams then maybe you would is it 50.1
now oh yeah
then um maybe you would enjoy watching
me on
um on Twitch so I'm just gonna put the
Twitch in the chat so you know
and also all my links are in the
description anyway
um but yeah feel free to follow me if
you're on Twitch and you can see more
live streams like this one but I just
wanted to do this one on YouTube because
I wanted to say a personal thank you to
you here on YouTube
um next video should be next Monday so I
hope you enjoy that one thank you so
much for answering the questions thank
you so much for asking the questions as
well
um I've seen lots of famous rockers
forget lyrics it happens yeah me too
actually yeah they're just very they're
very good at um winging it you know and
being like just going just keeping on
going so the crowd doesn't even know
it's like very good at that very good at
that improvisation I guess that's the
word for it you could ask us to make the
chat work as a teleprompter
I would not trust you with that I could
see y'all following me thank you so much
about that thanks Patrick
um but yeah thank you again so much
um also patreon it would be chaos it
would absolutely be chaos
uh patreons I'm actually going to as
soon as I finish the stream I'm gonna
upload a YouTube video for you to watch
uh it's gonna be the Early Access to
um my behind the scenes of how I'm
making my next music video so
um patreons will get access to that
and I think that's enough of me
um
telling you what to do promoting myself
that's the word thank you so much for
the followers on Twitch hopefully I will
see some of you there in my future
streams I stream on Mondays at um 7 00
a.m BST for a Monday morning motivation
streams and I also usually stream on
Thursdays at 8 30 p.m BST where we play
some games so if you're missing the
gameplay twitch is the place to be
because I play games every week over
there
they were confetti on the screen and she
couldn't see the lyrics
have a nice weekend Miss yag oh miss yag
that's so cute you too D Crow thank you
so much so actors smell the fart what do
singers do
yep I think it's time I go Bruce I have
no idea what you're talking about oh my
gosh here's the 50 more yeah hopefully
fingers crossed Nana I'm gonna say
goodbye to who I can see in the chat now
so goodbye to Nana goodbye to oh and
thank you so much Rambo for the follow
goodbye to unusual illusion goodbye Hui
goodbye Nikki goodbye uh Bruce Barra
goodbye miss gato goodbye space Wanderer
goodbye Jamie goodbye Michael Castilla
goodbye Nicholas P
um goodbye Miko
goodbye said Nita uh goodbye sud
uh
I feel okay by Mr Fahrenheit and
intellitron X if you're still around
and yeah goodbye to anyone who I might
have missed in the chat goodbye Leo and
goodbye to anyone who is watching and
not in the chat hello because I really
appreciate you being here as well so
have a little video evening I'll see you
in the next live stream on Twitch or the
next video on YouTube thanks again I
appreciate it I am saluting you
apparently I appreciate it have a lovely
day evening and goodbye
bye bye
bye